Hello, everybody. Thank you for being here.
I'm Meg Lota Brown. I'm the director of
the Graduate Center here at the
University. So welcome to this wonderful
resource which is John Singer, and we're
very fortunate to have him here. He's
He's the author of "Resume DNA: Succeeding
in Spite of Yourself," and he's also the
CEO of Professional Development
Strategies which is a Tucson based
company that equips clients with the
necessary tools to communicate their
strengths, and build and establish
professional networks, and secure
positions, get employed. He's a certified
professional resume writer and a career
coach with many years of experience, and
he's mentored professionals to identify
their unique skills and talents and
transition into meaningful and rewarding
careers. So he sounds like just the
person that we need. He's also worked as
a television writer and a member of the
Writers Guild of America, and he was
educated in business and marketing both
here at the U of A and at UCLA. In
addition to his own work as a writer, he
has a background in broadcasting
industry as a station owner and operator
and radio personality. So we're very
fortunate to have John here. Many of you
were here last week when he spoke to us
about, more specifically about resumes
and CVs, and today as you can see he's
speaking to us about strategic
interviewing and negotiating and
networking techniques. So please join me
in thanking John singer. [Audience applause]
Thank you, Dr. Brown and and thank you
and Dr. Hoit and David Bradshaw for
organizing this special event to help
people with career transition advice.
It's a very special accomplished group
of people. The TMAY, tell me about
yourself. It's the opening statement in
an interview. It's important to
immediately brand yourself as a
professional and show how your skills
and experience can solve the problems
within an organization. This allows you
to create an agenda of what you will be
talking about throughout the entire
interview. The TMAY empowers you to
control the interview from the onset and
should be delivered in about 60 seconds
or less.
This is that awkward moment in the
interview when they ask you to tell me
about yourself. When this request is made you need to be
able to present your unique skillset
without delay. I recently had a client
tell me that his first question was
would you like something to drink and
his answer was, "No, thank you. I had a beer on my drive over." Uh, that didn't go over
very well. He didn't really know his
audience. We all know the elevator speech.
It's used when you run into the decision
maker on the elevator and you have less
than 60 seconds to tell your story.
Most people freeze when they're asked
this question, "well, I like long walks on
the beach, pretty sunsets, and golden
retrievers." They just don't know how to
position themselves professionally. It's
difficult to talk about yourself at a
moment's notice, but you don't want to
miss a good opportunity. Several years
ago, our company had the bright idea of
creating videos of our clients to share
online. I instructed clients on how to
write a 60 second script, approximately
100 words, with a structured beginning
middle, and end. The opening included a
branding statement defining the level of
the professional, the middle section
communicated how the client does their
job, and the powerful close expressed
what the client could do for the
employer's company. This video was
actually a
verbal version of the profile that they
had on their resume document. Clients
rehearsed their scripts in front of
mirrors so they could see how they
appeared when they performed. They used
tape recorders to hear their energy and
enthusiasm or lack thereof in their
voices. We would set a cue card up by the
camera. When the clients read their lines
it appeared as if they were speaking
off-the-cuff,
looking deep into the eyes of their
audience. It was a good marketing tool.
The client could direct the potential
employer to a link with a brief profile
and a full resume in a little video box,
at that time it was about the size of a
business card, that played the client's
commercial. That's why we call it their
commercial. The videos were pretty simple.
The client was standing
in front of a white wall, the sound was
very tinny, their eyes were bouncing
around like pin balls. This is when
LinkedIn was in its infancy, but the
commercial, like LinkedIn, created an
online presence for the client. Well, the
idea started to take off and we quickly
improved the production value of the
videos. We would open with upbeat music
and an animated graphic with the client's
name filling the screen, fade in on the
client dressed to the nines and nestled
in a stylish business office with a
music bed
humming underneath as they read from a
teleprompter. As the client mentioned her
skill sets, bullet points would magically
appear over her shoulder showing her
impressive core competencies. Powerful
closing statement,
cut to animated graphic, music up and
under, fade to black.There you had it: the
60-second commercial. Well, these were
quite popular back then. HR managers and
C-level execs loved the new concept. They could
look beyond the paper resume and
actually see personality and credibility.
They were motivated to meet the
applicant for an interview. Then YouTube
became very popular. Everybody and his
brother and sister were creating video
resumes. HR departments were inundated
with these moving pictures and online
links, so the fad faded quickly. There
were actually lawsuits filed against
companies in which applicants claim that
they were rejected due to their videos.
You don't like the color of my
tie or my skin or my age.  This is when we
pulled the plug on this monster we had
created, but I always learned something
from all or most of my clients. I learned
a valuable lesson when we patiently
produced all of these commercials. Most
clients were a little clumsy in front of
the camera.
Some would stare at the lens speechless
with the glazed look in their eyes, their
only goal was to get through this
agonizing video without stammering
stumbling or embarrassing themselves. So
what did I learn from this? Well, when you
have a goal of successfully moving from
point A, which in this case was the
opening of the commercial, and reaching
point B, the close, everything in
between is incidental. The client had
already organized their thoughts and
written them in a script. We had edited
the script and they
became familiar with the structured
beginning branding statement, middle
accomplishments, and the end their
powerful close, which were all
customized for the job opportunity. When
they prepared this video presentation,
they really mastered the format and
delivery of an opening statement and now
they could do it at any time and in the
interview. Most job applicants fail to
take advantage of this perfect
opportunity to make a great first
impression. Out of nervousness, they may
talk excessively and reveal personal
information, which can be damaging/
Interviews are performances. Performances
must be practiced. You are being judged
the minute you open your mouth. Like it
or not, you are performing. And what's the
first rule of show business? Know your
audience. Be sure to address their needs,
find their pain, and show them how you
can solve their problems. Everything that
you share should be relevant to the job
and the company. When one of my clients
delivers their commercial in an
interview the interviewers jaw usually
drops. They're not used to this - that's a
good thing.
The interviewer is delighted to hear a
structured statement that is
personalized to the company and the
position. The applicant has immediately
established a rapport and created an
agenda
of what they will discuss throughout the
interview. They have taken control in the
first minute of conversation. They can
now expand on the skills and talents
that they advertise in their opening
statement, and can easily refer back to
these accomplishments that they
strategically inserted in the TMAY.
I put my clients through a process. It
starts with a formal script. The content
is structured and organized and includes
a power close. It's important to have a
definitive close. Wrap up the TMAY
with what you can offer the organization.
Most applicants end their opening
statements with selfish pitches, "I'm
seeking an upper-level management
position in operations where I can grow
within the company and take the
organization to greater heights." That's
self centered. It's better to close with
what you can bring to the company, not
what you want for yourself. Better
example, "With my PMP certification,
expertise in lean manufacturing, and
application of Six Sigma principles, I
will increase productivity and profits
for a progressive organization."
That's much better.
Another important reason for the power
close, is to show that you've finished
talking.
You're now turning the interview over to
the interviewer. I then have the client
read the script to me word-for-word.
They sound scripted, awkward, over-rehearsed,
but they're familiarizing themselves
with the structured beginning, the
branding statement,  middle, their
accomplishments,  and end, a power close
which were all customized for the job
opportunity. We now discuss their
performance. Was she confident and
believable? How was her pacing and
enunciation? Was her energy consistent
from the beginning to the end? I then
have a client reduce the script to four
bullets, short sentences that summarize
the script. Bullet one: opening, it's your
branding statement. Bullet two: what you
do. Bullet three: how you do it. In bullet
four: your power close.
We then turned the script over and the
client presents their opening statement
from the bullet points. This allows them
to speak naturally, use their personality,
and powerfully close their statement in
under one minute. It's amazing to watch
this transformation. The client speaks
with confidence, looks into my eyes, and
delivers the message with clarity and
conviction. It works every time. Few job
applicants open with clear and concise
statements. Again, you're taking control
of the interview in the first 60 seconds,
and you can now refer back to these
powerful skill sets throughout the
interview. So, when you're driving to the
interview, and you're organizing your
thoughts of your TMAY, ask yourself
the following questions. How am I
branding myself for this position? What
are the key components that they are
seeking for the perfect applicant? How
can I close by showing them what I am
qualified to do for this position? It's
easy to commit a few bullets to memory;
if you've already created a script, you
can paraphrase from it naturally. If you
know yourself as a professional and know
how you can successfully accomplish a
company's goals and objectives, you can
deliver your TMAY credibly anytime,
anywhere. Always remember, in any
interview, always bring your three E's
with you.
What are they? Energy, enthusiasm, and
energy. Now that your opening statement
is fresh on your mind, what else have you
done to prepare for the interview? Do
your homework on the company and the
position. Do your homework on yourself to
show your fit within the company and the
position. Anticipate interview questions.
Prepare a list of questions that will
uncover problems or pain points within
the company, and be prepared to show how
you can solve these problems. What do you
plan to wear to the interview? It's
important to consider that.
Always present yourself as a
professional. I often prepare my clients
a day before the interview by conducting
a mock interview and throw difficult
questions at them, rake them over the
coals. One morning I was coaching a
client who had an interview scheduled
for later that day. Mary Kay, that's her
name, was an animated Southern woman who
jingled with every gesture. She dressed
impeccably, but was quite over stocked
with her jewelry and perfume.
Whenever she made a movement her gold bracelets
clanged and reverberated like Santa's
sleigh bells. Her overly applied
fragrance would make my eyes water and
it would linger in my office hours after
her departure. I knew I had to discuss
this with her. It wasn't going to be easy.
It was my job as her coach to
diplomatically persuade her to reduce
her perfume and jewelry by 95%. So she
took it like I thought she would, and she
was a little frustrated and flustered by
my suggestions, but in her southern way
she found herself with her scarlet red
fingertips and gasped, "Well, I had no idea!
I'll certainly follow your professional
advice. You're entitled to your opinion,
bless your heart." Being from Oklahoma, I
know exactly what "bless your heart" means.
It is often applied as an antiseptic
after a cutting remark. "He's as dumb as a
bag of bricks, bless his heart."
Well, she followed my advice and did an
excellent job with her interview. She
called me the next day and was very
excited, and told me that she had
accepted an offer and started work that
following Monday. Well good for you, Mary
Kay. Bless your heart. Always dress a
grade above or match the style of the
management team for the organization. It
shows you respect the interviewer and
the interview process. Well, this is the
exciting time of our talk. I have a
wonderful volunteer who is going to come to
our microphone, and I'm going to ask her
some interview questions. I'm not going
to be hard.
She told me she just had an interview
today, which is great, and I said, "well
after being in a room full of people,
every interview will be easy for you." But
please go ahead and step up and
introduce yourself.
[Contreras] Hi, I'm Yissel Contreras.
[Singer] And tell us a little bit about
yourself.
[Contreras] I am a neuroscientist with a background in chemical engineering, material science and semiconductor processing. I
like solving challenging problems by
using critical thinking and systematic
approaches. I like collaborating with
others. Um.... [Singer] You're doing a wonderful job. Looks like you really listened to the
first part of this discussion. [Contreras] I like working on complex topics, and
I will perform any task with by
exceeding expectations. [Singer] Very good, very
good. Well, let me ask you a few questions,
and answer them quickly, honestly. Try and
remember, you know, when you're talking
and giving me your answer to keep your
answers to about a minute, really no more.
If the interviewer wants to know more, they'll ask you follow up questions and
you're invited to expand on that idea. So,
my first question to you: how do you
perform under stress in the workplace? [Contreras]
Well, I usually when facing a challenging
like a stress environment, I develop a
plan. It's useful to know my strengths, my
resources, and also my time constraints.
So my basic approach is I'll develop a
plan, follow up with the people I need to
collaborate with, and probably just um....
[Singer] That's good. I would have ended right
there. That was very good because what
most people don't - there's a couple
things about that question that you need
to know. That was a how question. Whenever
you're asked a how question, they're
looking for your recipe or your formula
as to how you do something. When you ask,
you know, how do you do that? Quite well,
but that's what the magician says after
he performed his trick so he doesn't
have to explain to you how he did it. But
she explained how she performs in a
stressful environment so that was very good.
What you don't know, most people don't
know, about the stress
question is to an HR person or the
person asking you this question stress
is a four-letter word. I know it has six
letters in it I use my fingers earlier
to count it up, but it is a signal that
things are beyond one's control, it's
always used as a crutch or as an excuse
in the workplace, and it's used
frequently. So I suggest that you answer
the question, but redefine the word. Don't
repeat the word stress. Choose a word of
something you can control, and then of
course explain how you how you do that.
So I would answer it more like, "Well,
certainly in our work environment, we're
faced daily with unexpected problems or
challenges. When I have an unexpected
problem arise, I analyze the problem. I'll
consult with my team. I want their input
on it. I go back and I work out a
solution. Then I implement the solution."
So I didn't use the word stress, I used
the word "problem" and a problem is
something that we can control. Very good.
Here's sounds like an easy question, but
it's a loaded question. Would you be
willing to relocate?
[Volunteer] Um, yes, I would have no problem relocating.
Okay I wanted to see
how long it took you to answer that. If
you pause too long, they assume that you
will not do that. The correct answer is,
"Certainly, depending on the opportunity,
I'd be happy to relocate." And that's also
true with the "what about excessive
travel?" Certainly depending on the
opportunity I'd be happy to do that. They
might want to move you to Denver in nine
months. That's why they ask this early on.
If you are not willing to relocate, the
interview is probably over in their mind.
You want to get to an offer at the end
of this interview, so you'll never get
there if you give a negative reply. And I
don't care if you're wearing an ankle
bracelet and the sheriff won't let you
leave the county, there might be a judge
that can give you a work release program.
There is a way that you can relocate if
the opportunity is the best opportunity
for you. Next question. This is the Big
Kahuna of all trap questions, but I want
you to answer it just quickly and
honestly for me, please. Tell me, professionally,
what's your greatest weakness? [Contreras] So I
sometimes tend to overthink when
planning something. So it means, um, I think
too much about the little details that
will come up in the future and need to
constantly remind myself that I must
focus on the closest challenge at hand
and then the small details will be
addressed later. [Singer] And what is negative
about you overthinking something? Does it
slow you down? Are you... [Contreras] It can slow me
down so that's why I developed this
strategy to constantly remind me this is
what's next and then I will face future
challenges when when it's time to do that. So it's it's a matter of the time
it consumes and the energy thinking
about problems that may not be there in
the future. [Singer] Okay, she's almost on to
something there. You know she admitted to
overthinking things which slows her down,
she's tied into the minutia of the day
to day, and that could be a red flag, but
she did tell us how she was overcoming
it. I don't know if she has overcome it
or not, the thing to remember here is to
never really admit to something that
they think you will bring to their table.
So I would answer that question, if you
had asked me, I'd say, "I can't think of
any weaknesses that would apply to this
position but if any were pointed out to
me, I do my best to overcome them. Let me
give you an example. Earlier in my career
when I was a younger manager, I was a bit
of a perfectionist, which i think is an
asset, but I always had to do things on
my own.
And I was given my first project to
manage earlier in my career, and I went
ahead and did it all on my own and
ignored this wonderful team that was
sitting in front of me. Well, fortunately
for me a senior level manager came over,
and took me aside, and said, "John these
people are probably, no they are
definitely a lot smarter than you are,
and you have this wonderful team here
and this is your chance to be a leader
to draw from their experience and lead
them on this.
So I followed his advice and the project
came out much better than if I just done
it on my own. That was the day I think I
became a leader and a good project
manager and I've been practicing it that
way ever since." So what did I accomplish
there? I didn't admit to anything that
I'm bringing to your company if you hire
me. I did answer the question, so I
brought up, like you, I brought up a
weakness and I showed you how I got
through that and I pretty much assured
you that I'm not going to bring it to
your company. So, always remember to put
it in your past. The similar question to
that would be give us three - they asked
this - give us three of your greatest
professional failures. And I would never
do that. I mean, you're not gonna get
points for telling the truth and giving
me your weaknesses and failures, so I
would think of maybe something that
potentially could have been a failure,
have catastrophic results, but I would
give them the story like I just told
that other story and walk them through
and show them how I saved it from being
a failure. It might not have been a
tremendous success, but that would be the
story that I would use. That's showing my
skill sets and how I can work on a
problem and solve that problem. Okay, this
is a question that many of you may hear
because of what you do and where you are.
"Do you expect any difficulties
transitioning from your world, your
industry, into ours?
[Contreras] Possibly, yes. In my
experience I've made transitions between
disciplines and also between
environments for instance moving to
doing an undergrad in Mexico to doing
going to grad school here. And I
basically learned that in new
environments that there's basically two
things one is learning, the new language,
not only as Spanish from English but
also the new technical terms that are
associated with that environment or that
science. And the other is learning the
new rules. So it's all about being
flexible, and being adaptable, so even
though I am not an expert in industry,  I
know I would be able to adapt, to learn
the new rules
and I expect I expect not everything to
be perfect at first but I know I will
learn fast.
[Singer] Okay, that was good
explanation. I think what they're mostly
concerned about is the timeline. How
long is it going to take you to get up
to speed in their industry? They
obviously think that you have the right
skills, education, etc., to the interview
and have this job. Where they're mostly
concerned, you need to put them at ease
that it won't take us a long time, so I
recommend that you pick something that
you did in your past in your past
position where you were facing change,
and you show them where you came in
under time, under budget very quickly.
That you learn quickly. They're concerned
that you're going to take a long time
for you to get up to speed. So that's how
I would reduce it. I would always always
think of a story of accomplishment that
you can use in your answers. Last
question.
Alright, let me set the stage, so the
person you're interviewing with is a
little concerned. He's very impressed
with you,
thinks you're wonderful. You have a
wonderful resume - not a long CV - it's a
two-page resume. It's beautiful
and he's worried that you're
overqualified, that you're gonna be bored,
that you're gonna leave, you're gonna go
work for his competition. That you're
ambitious, you want the next job. It's his.
He doesn't want to give it up. This is
what's on his mind, okay. Let's say you
and I talked before that interview, and I
told you, I said do you think you're a
little overqualified for this? You might
say, "yes I might appear to be, but this is
a great opportunity. I love the widget
industry. I would love to be a part of it
I love challenges. I I think this would
be a great opening for me in my career."
Well, I'm going to tell you that you need
to share that passion with them the next
day in the interview because that's
gonna probably be the elephant in the
room. They may bring it up, they might not.
So I'll give you a good way of answering
that, but let's just assume that's what
is happening here. How are you going to
convince them otherwise? So my question
to you is are you overqualified for this
position?
[Contreras] Well, I certainly believe there are,
possibly, many specialities in my
background and not all of them would be
utilized in this job, but this is... these
are highly specialized, tasks I would be
asked to learn how to specialize, so I
see it as an opportunity to learn.
Learning more in-depth about a specific
aspect of, let's say semiconductor
processing, much more than I would have
the opportunity to do that in academia,
so I I don't see it as being too simple
or too easy but rather as an
opportunity to learn more in depth about
the specific area of what I learned
[Singer] Okay.
I like that explanation. I can give you a
fast way of making that much shorter and
using a magic word at the end of it to uh
hopefully seal the deal for yourself. I
would say, if you asked me that question,
and this is like the stress question, you
don't necessarily want to use the word
overqualified. So you say are you
overqualified for this position. I would
say, "No, I really don't think that I am.
You know, we've discussed your goals of
how to grow this organization. I have had
that same plan in my experience. I know
that I can help you get there. I know
there will be a lot of challenges. I
embrace challenges, they excite me. I
believe that I am not overqualified as
much as I'm prepared." So prepared is the
word and if you would have tacked that
on the end of what you just told me, I
think that would have made your answer
much better because that shows them that
you're prepared for people that are
older like me, I see a lot of younger
faces in here, but if I have a younger
candidate that I'm competing against,
when I say that I'm prepared they're
gonna be very interested in that. They're
paying for my experience whereas the
younger candidate might not know how to
get them to their goals. So by saying
you're prepared, I think, is a better way
of saying that you're overqualified. Well,
thank you very much everybody give her a
round of applause. [Applause]
We have your resume on file and we may
give you a call soon. Before you go to
the company's website to fill out the
application, you need to have a good idea
of the compensation range for this
position in your market. If asked to
specify a salary, you don't want to come
in too low and certainly not too high. So
here's what you do. You go online and you
search for a free salary calculator, and
you can do this through Salary Wizard,
which I believe is part of Monster,
salary.com. This is a free service. It
lists every job, really, you can think of
in United States, in every marketplace,
and it shows you different pay ranges in
those particular markets. In Tucson,
unfortunately, sometimes the same job at
Honeywell in Tucson, Arizona, would pay
more in Phoenix. So you really need to
understand what they're paying in that
market. So you open up the salary
calculator, and it usually asks you three
questions. What's the position? Let's say,
project manager engineer. What's the
industry? Aerospace. What's the market?
Tucson, Arizona. After you complete the
questions, you'll see results of various
levels for the position. Suppose this is
a level three job, as it was described,
and it's in the posting and level three
would pay the most.
It's paying between seventy and eighty
five thousand dollars, so they publish
the range in this marketplace for that.
They also say that this level requires a
master's degree, a PMP certification, ten
years of experience. It lists all the job
responsibilities. And this is what you
saw pretty much in the job posting, so
you say yup this is the one. So now you
have an idea of what the range is for
that position. So now you need to
establish your acceptable salary range
and create a walkaway number in your
mind. With your skills education and
experience, you will show the company
where you can add value, and hopefully
break that $85,000 barrier, and we'll
talk about that a little bit later, but
you need to decide you decide that you
want to make at least $80,000 which is a
median number and
range. Later in the negotiation, if by
chance the company comes in with a low
offer like 68, you can turn around and
show them that, according to your
research, the job requires 80 thousand
dollars plus an experienced education
and credentials. So you can set them back
on track. They've seen these numbers as
well. So now you're prepared to tackle
the online application. One of the first
inquiries online usually is what are
your salary requirements. So you enter
the word "open," and you immediately get a
bounce back. It says, "must enter a numeric
value." While this puts you at an
immediate disadvantage, at least you did
your homework and have established the
documented salary range for this
particular market. If the position
described is clearly level 3, you should
enter a median figure in that box,
$80,000, and you'll be safe. You didn't go
to high you didn't go to low. If you're
invited for a face-to-face interview,
you'll be able to justify the $80,000
figure and show where you can add value,
and, perhaps, you can move this number to
85,000 or beyond. During the interviewer
interview, the interviewer may ask you
your salary expectations. And this is
very uncomfortable and you want to
please them, and you don't want to be
rude, but you really need to stand up for
yourself in this one. You might say the
average for this market is around
$80,000, your compensation could be more
it could be less. Let's discuss this
position and clarify the job
responsibilities as you see them, and
then I will be happy to give you an
answer of the compensation a little bit
later. So what you're asking them to
do is describe what this job is to you
and your company.
You know you might pay me $250,000 for
this job if you expect me to rotate all the
tires in the parking lot and paint the
building three times a day. I just
will burn out very quickly. I'm sorry. My
point is you want to know what they want
you to do for this money, so it makes
sense, it's logical for them to explain
this job to you so hopefully they will
go on and explain the job to you. Now the
interviewer might ask you another tricky question.
What are you currently making? This is an
unfair question, and, as many of you know,
is actually illegal in many states right
now. So why give them a yardstick to
measure you by? Your best response would
be this, and I think it's a good one, "I
believe we can both agree that I'm
qualified for this position, but the
responsibilities posted for this job are
quite different than my current role, so
I believe it's unfair to compare the two.
Could we discuss this position further,
and after I understand your expectations
and responsibilities associated with the
job, I can give you an accurate answer?"
And that's just telling them, again, these
are two different jobs. I'm, It doesn't mean
I'm not qualified, but don't compare my
current job to this job. It's very
different. That will usually work, but
they'll definitely bring it up at the
end of the interview. During the
interview, they'll ask you behavioral
questions testing your management style,
your technical aptitude, your
communication skills. Then they will
reach a critical point of the interview
when they ask you if you have any
questions for them. I call this the
benchmark point of the interview. This
reveals they have given you a complete
description of the job and its
responsibilities in their mind.
Throughout the interview you've been
looking for holes on their side. What,
you're interviewing them as well. What
did they forget to mention? In other
words, what is there that you think you
can do for the organization that they
did not list as the job responsibilities?
This is where you can uncover areas
where you can add value to the position.
So when you're asked, you should have a
list of questions that you're going to
ask them, but the first one you ask them
should be something like this, "Where do
you see the company, department, growing
in the next 6 to 12 months and what
areas do you wish to improve upon? What
goals and objectives have not been met?
This is where you will uncover problems
that you can solve. You're looking for
their pain, and if you take on these
additional responsibilities, you should
be paid for
this added value that you're bringing to
the organization. The reason why we wait
until this point in the interview to
bring up these topics of added value is
to show what we can do over and beyond
what they are expecting. They just
outlined what they thought this job was.
Now you're showing them that you can do
more than that.
Most of your competition will not be
doing that. If we had brought these
additional responsibilities up
prematurely,
they'd say, "Sure, we'd love for you to do
that. It's part of your job." And then they
would have absorbed those added
responsibilities and merged it into that
low salary base. The added value that you
bring to the position translates to the
highest end of the pay range and beyond.
So at this point if they ask you what
the position should pay, you can answer
with confidence because you've talked
about the position and you've also done
your research. You would say, "According to
my research in the Tucson market for
this position that you describe, the
compensation is upward" - use that word -
"upward to $85,000. With the additional
responsibilities that we just discussed,
the compensation would be in the mid 90s."
So you've shown them clearly that if
you'd like for me to do these other
responsibilities you're gonna have to
pay me more money. Money can also be made
in negotiating your benefits package, for
performance bonuses, additional time off
stronger health care coverage, in 401k
matching. This is all covered in this
book that you will receive through David.
He's gonna send you an electronic copy of
the book, and it's under the chapter
called "Well Played, Sir," and you'll see
several more strategies for negotiation.
You should take advantage of every
networking opportunity you possibly can.
Events such as today's meeting, industry
events, project management institute
lectures - that's PMI. Any event where you
can meet a c-level decision maker,
colleagues, or professionals in your
industry. We call this the unpublished
job market. Nearly 70% of upper level
positions are secured through networking.
Not online.
It's all about who you know and who they
know, so take it upon yourself to contact
local industry leaders and request to
have an informational exchange, either on
the phone or face-to-face. You're not
asking them for a job. You're exchanging
information. You're expanding your
network and hopefully you're gonna be
walking away with some referrals that
can lead you to opportunities to help
you advance in your career. How many of
you are active on LinkedIn? That's great.
It's better than last time.
LinkedIn is an excellent online
networking tool. You should connect with
me. Look me up. I have about 2500
connections. And I'm not bragging or
boasting because I don't know any of
them really, but the point here is you
can see my connections. You can put in
Raytheon or Roche or see who I'm
connected to at those places, and then
you can connect with them through me. So
connect with me and expand your contact
base. If you have a hundred contacts,
you should work on expanding it to three
hundred contacts within the next six
months. It's easy to do. Be sure you have
an updated profile and a professional
picture, not that little cartoon
silhouette they have there as a default.
It's very important. They won't take you
seriously unless you have a picture and
not one with somebody's arm on your
shoulder or you in a crown. When you're
on LinkedIn you can follow companies of
interest, you can join discussion groups,
you can start your own discussion group,
you can write articles and post them.
You're showing you're an expert in your
field and you're really expanding your
network. And when you have an active
LinkedIn account, you will start
receiving postings because companies are
searching for people like you and they
will see your activity and they will
actually send you job postings. I coach
clients all over the US and beyond,
and they eventually find success, all of
them, but the clients who are successful
most quickly, are those who have proper
marketing collateral, an excellent
communication strategy as we discussed
today,
and they're totally committed and
engaged in their job search. My father
taught me the most important lessons
that I know about business and life,
really.
A few of his many pearls of wisdom that I
want to share with you, they'll never
leave me. The first one, surround yourself
with people more talented than you. And
in my case, that's never hard to do.
There's a good example. Success is
measured by how you have inspired others.
Do what you love and happiness will
follow. Never, ever give up. And most
importantly, go out and make it happen.
One day he took me aside and made an
observation that I hope was a compliment.
I still haven't really figured it out. He
put his hand on my shoulder, and with a
warm smile and his southern gentlemen's
charm, he said, "Son, you're the kind of guy
that will succeed in spite of himself." I
hope I haven't let him down. My parting
advice to you is visualize yourself at
your best and then go out and make it
happen. Thank you. [Applause]
[Attendee] On the overqualified question,  I
was in an interview where it did not
come up, but at the end of the interview I
was turned down by the employer with the
comment that they thought I was
overqualified for the position. So if they
don't bring it up,
should I, assuming that I think a lot of
industry people consider somebody who
has a PhD, at least for a certain
entry-level positions, by default
overqualified yet somehow also at the
same time not experienced enough? But so
how do you, like, if it's not explicitly
addressed, how to deal with that?
[Singer] The more
you interview, thank you, the more
you interview, the easier it will be for
you to weave certain things into your
conversation. This is part of your
strategy. So like I said earlier, that was
the elephant in the room. You might have
known that when you walked in there and
you were surprised he didn't ask you. You
might have been anticipating that with
your educational background, so I would
recommend that if you see something that
you know you can answer and put them at
ease, I would weave that into my
conversation. When they ask you if you
have any questions for them, it's your
turn to talk and you can give them any
information that you need, but show them
your passion. You know, don't just say it,
show it. And show them that you're
passionate for this type of position.
Tell them why it would be a great
position for you going from academia
into this field and that might work for
you.
[Attendee] Good afternoon or good evening, and
thank you. The question is with regards
to ageism. That's the other elephant in
the room, particularly female ageism. So
how, what could you offer some elegant
responses or elegant anticipation since
that's in the room?
[Singer] Great question. It is
out there, and many times they'll try and
find it through the applicant tracking
system as they're scanning resumes to
figure out how old you are. That's why on
the resume we never put years of degrees.
You might have had an MBA from 1989.
That's wonderful but an MBA from 2015
would have been fresher and more
interesting to me. You also revealed your
age. So,
we, you know, we walk in there and they
see you, know what we look like, and so
that's obvious, but you're very vibrant
and age shouldn't be an issue. If they
ask you any questions about age, which we
know is off-limits, this is what I tell,
and particularly my female clients that
get asked "are you married? Do you have
any kids?,"
these are improper questions, and I
always tell them to answer with, "is that
important for this position?"
So age would be the same thing, is it
important for this position. I think we
go back to the overqualified question,
where I say prepared. I think you ought
to take a little language out of there
and, not to that question, but throughout
the interview, let them know how well you
are prepared for this job. Your age would
be an asset. Like I said to the other
person who's much younger than you,
so show them that, and if they're gonna
pay you and pay you more, it's worth it.
It's worth the investment and it's not
an age factor, it's an experience and
expertise. My company, we embrace age
because we know that they know their
stuff and we love to work with people.
[Attendee] So that transitions to the second part of
the question which is, um, because of the age
and the experience you're too expensive.
[Singer] They might think that and that's hard to
get around
and that's another elephant that might
be in the room. You might need to be able
to tell them if you are willing to work
for a certain salary that might be less
than what you were making it the last
job and you understand that in this
industry, based on your research, this
position pays a little bit less than
what I was making in my previous
position but I'm fine with that. I enjoy
the challenge. I want to have the
opportunity to work for this company, to
work with a large group of people, and to
grow with them. So the figure isn't as
important to me as the position. So you
want to try and get off that number. You
might have to take less. They should pay
you to the highest end of any scale
because you have that expertise. [Attendee] Thank
you. [Singer] Thank you.
[Attendee] Hello and thank you. My question is about
salary and negotiation. How, what is a
political and appropriate way to ask
them, when they are asking me about
expected salary, how can I ask them am I
going to be paid as much as a male
candidate is going to be paid?
[Singer] That's a
great question, particularly today.
They'll never admit to that, they'll
never talk to you about that.
If they're practicing that, it's it's
wrong, but I think through talking to
other people in the organization or in
your market or in your industry to find
out are women being paid less than men
for the same work. It's something that
needs to be brought up. It's a question
that you might, if you accept the job, and
if it's not too far, you know in a gap
from what the male is making, that your
counterpart that's working right next to
you, I would address that to the HR
department because that is very common
in these days and it's unfair. That is
why I mentioned earlier that it's
illegal in many states - Massachusetts,
California, and a few others, and it's
gonna be widespread - to ask what you're
making.
They put that law into effect to protect
women because they wanted to see what
women were making so they could pay them
less. So that's why that law went into
play. So it's it's on the minds of
everybody. I think HR departments,
particularly these days, particularly
with things that are going on in the
workplace and then we hear about on the
news, they're very sensitive to some of
these things where they might not have
been a few years ago and that would be
something you could discuss with HR.
Or you could gently discuss it with them
during the negotiation. Once you reach
the negotiation, you have every right to
discuss that salary, what you're
contributing, and is that in line with
the other employees what they're making.
[Attendee] Regarding networking, can you give
us more advices or details about how it
can we strengthen our networking?
[Singer] Can you repeat that. I didn't hear the
first part of the question.
[Attendee] Okay, regarding the network. [Singer] Networking?
[Attendee] Yeah, networking. So how can
what advice that you can tell us or
advise us to strength our networking?
[Singer] Great question.
Networking should be something that you
do, even if you're in a job you're gonna
be in that job for 10 or 15 years. This
is why you see people going to events,
um, having meetings with other people
over lunch. People that are their peers
in their industry. A way that you, and all
of you can strengthen your networking, is
through research. You might find a
company you want to work for. They might
not be offering a job right now, but you
want to target a decision maker - that's a
person one or two levels above your
desired position - and let them know that
you would like to have a conversation
with them. You're not expecting them to
know of a job. You're trying to expand
your network. You believe that someone
with their background and expertise
would be a great resource for
information. Could we talk? And when you
go and you talk with them, you talk about
the industry, and you're sharing things
about yourself. They're learning about
you, but you're not making this a job
interview. You came in there with the
idea that you are going to talk about
the industry. So you're asking them
questions, they're asking you questions,
and you're developing a relationship and
you want to continue to nourish those
relationships throughout your career. So
you want to follow up with them. They
might be interested. Did you get that job?
Yes, I did. This is my new contact
information. Thanks for your help. I did
contact the person you were recommending
that I get in touch with. One of the
greatest things about networking is if I
go and talk with you and we're chatting
about your industry and exchanging
information, I'm also asking you who
would you also recommend that I speak to
within your company? Or who would you
recommend I speak to outside of your
company? Great, can I use your name?
Wonderful, fantastic. Then I write a
referral letter to that person.
Dear Mr. Johnson, in a recent
conversation with David Finer, he
suggested that I get in touch with you.
David, I am expanding my network in the
Tucson marketplace in the widget
industry and David thought you would be
an excellent source of information, so
based on his recommendation I would like
to have a brief meeting with you. So I
just mentioned his name three times.
You know David, you're gonna, you're gonna
see me. And this is how we expand that
network and we fall into opportunities
that aren't published online.
[Attendee] I have a question about the salary negotiation
part of the interview. Is that a standard
part of like the first interview or the
second interview? If it doesn't come up
does that mean they've already made a
decision not to hire me?
[Singer] Great question.
It's rarely done in the first interview.
Usually in particularly upper-level
positions, you your first interview might
be a phone screening, it might be a
screening face-to-face with someone in
HR or a hiring manager, and then you're
usually going to go through two or three
other interviews where they're getting
very serious. They might ask you to work
a problem for them or create a
presentation just to see if you have the
right stuff or is she just what we see on
the paper.
So these discussions really happen later
in the second or third interview, but you
need to be prepared for them. In the
first interview you must be must be
prepared for them. So you can expect it
to come later, but it sometimes they need
somebody, they love you and what you do,
and they can hire you on the spot. I've
seen everything happen, but never accept
an offer on the day that it is extended
to you. Always tell them, you know, use the
family card, I would like to discuss this
with my family could I get back to you
in the next two or three business days.
Sure. And also ask them, "Could you please
send me the job description that we just
discussed all the responsibilities and
give me your offer, along with your
benefits package, that way I can review
it with my family?" Well, now you have a
document, and that whatever number that
was, it's attached to these job
responsibilities, so they can't add more
when you go to work for them or you go
to HR and you tell them I need to be
paid for doing Bill's job. Also, the
benefits package you can study closely.
Are the healthcare benefits better than
mine?
Great, yes they are. Oh they don't start
for 90 days, there's a probation period. I
was laid off my last job.
I have six people in my family. I have a
COBRA payment of $1,000 a month. I'm
gonna ask them, part of my negotiation
will be, "can you cover my COBRA payments
while I'm in this probation period, or
could you reduce it to 30 days and still
cover my COBRA payments?" Yes, we'd be glad
to. Now I just saved myself $3,000. So
there are always things within that
benefits package that we can negotiate.
You know, I tell clients, my company
provides outplacement services for when
people get downsized, so I always ask
them to negotiate outplacement services,
and out and negotiate the length of
their severance. And the person might say,
you know, "I haven't hired you yet. You're,
you're trying to find out what I'm gonna
pay you when I fire you?" And I have them
tell them, "Well, I don't know of a better
time to talk about it. Very gently, is
that that you know or is it that you
don't know? Could we talk to HR?" So you
could say that you know I would like to
have the severance extended to four
months. It's currently 30 days, according
to your company policy, and they could
ask and there could be a thousand
employees a 999 have 30 days and you
have three months. And it doesn't mean
anything to them it, doesn't cost them
anything. It's like an insurance policy.
When I buy it, I'm bidding I'm going to
die. The insurance agent is betting I'm
going to live, so we're trying to
determine how we're going to do this and
what the best rates will be.
[Brown] John, I just want to
say thank you so much for being here, and
thank you to everyone who is here, as
well. And also thank you so much to David
Bradshaw, whose name keeps being invoked,
and because he does so much. Thanks so
much.
[Singer] Thank you, David.
[Singer] And I would
like to thank all of you for taking time
out of your day to listen to these ideas.
Enjoy the book. I think you'll get a lot
out of it. If you can walk away with one
or two good ideas, I think our time was
well spent. Thank you very much.